Officials in New Jersey are investigating a possible alarming link...
...between cases of brain cancer and a high school there.
105 former students and staff report being diagnosed with brain tumors...
...going back decades, about half of them cancerous.
Health experts are calling the rate concerning.
Environmental engineers are now testing the grounds for radiation.
Here's ABC's Zachary Kiesh.
Tonight, there are questions surrounding this New Jersey high school...
...and a possible link to brain tumors.
I want answers.
I wanna know that there is something or there is nothing there.
Al Lupiano wondered if there was a possible connection after he, his wife,...
…and his sister Angela, all former students were diagnosed with brain tumors.
Al's tumor was discovered 20 years ago.
His wife and sister received their diagnosis last August.
Angela died this year.
I had recalled two family friends,...
…the Black sisters, had also passed of these brain tumors.
That started setting off bells and whistles in my head.
Lupiano made a plea on Facebook,...
...searching for anyone else in the area who had a similar experience.
So far, 105 former students and staff connected to Colonia High School...
...say they have been diagnosed with primary brain tumors,...
...about half were cancerous.
The cases spanned three decades.